حظر الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق ارسوي مما
وصفها بازمه دستوريه تاريخيه تتهدد البلاد
في اشاره الى تصاعد الخلاف بين المعارضه
والحكومه بشان تعديلات يسعى نتنياهو
لادخالها على منظومه القضاء بالتزامن مع
تصاعدي العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه
من الشهداء والجرحى بين الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات من حيثياته وابعاده
الازمه السياسيه الراهنه التي تمر بها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والتي حضر الرئيس
الاسرائيلي من تحولها الى ازمه دستوريه
تاريخيه وكيف
يتعاطى نتنياهو مع هذه التطورات هذه
الازمه السياسيه التي يؤجها هذا الملف
وغيره وكيف هي صله بين ذلك وتصعيد الامنيه
الاسرائيليه المتواصل في الضفه وما الذي
قد تنتهي اليه هذه الازمه في اسرائيل في
ضوء المؤشرات الراهنه وكيف للقوى
الفلسطينيه ان تتعامل مع مجرياتها
ونتائجها المحتمله
[موسيقى]
نقش ان تتحول اسرائيل الى ديكتاتوريه
واقعه تحت سيطره اغلبيه برلمانيه ذا كما
تردد في تصريحات شخصيات قضائيه واخرى
سياسيه معارضه وهي تعلق على ما تضمنه
برنامج
القضائي خطه قال وزير الدفاع السابق بنقاس
انهار لخلاف عميق بين الحكومه والمعارضه
ينذر بنشوب حرب الاهليه في البلاد بدوره
حضر رئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق اسرائيل ترزح
تحت القسام عميق يثير القلق الشديد
ويستدعي حوارا عميقا لتجاوزه في المقابل
هون نتنياهو من الازمه قائلا ان خطه
الاصلاح القضائي مثلت واحده من اهم
القضايا التي صوت لصالحها الناخب
الاسرائيلي عندما اعاده الى الحكم في اخر
انتخابات تشريعيه
وفيما يستمر الجدل بشان خطط نتنياهو
الحكوميه والتعيينات التي تشمل اعلى
المناصب الامنيه تلك التي افضت الى تنصيب
هيرسي هاليفي رئيسا لهيئه الاركان في
الجيش الاسرائيلي وصى اصوات الرافضه لذلك
تواصل قوات الاحتلال عملياتها العسكريه في
الضفه الغربيه موقعه بين يوم واخر اعدادا
متزايده من الشهداء والجرحى بين
الفلسطينيين في اخر التطورات جراحه
فلسطينيون برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي اقتحمت بلده قباطيه جنوب جنين وشهيد
فلسطيني سقط في مخيم الدهيشه جنوب مدينه
بيت لحم الضفه الغربيه الذي شهد مواجهات
بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت المخيم فجرا
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تل ابيب يا
العليمه مراسله شؤون العسكريه في راديو
اسرائيل
نتنياهو وحديثه عن ان الناخب الاسرائيلي
هو من صوت الى مثل هذه التعديلات وتحذيرات
من عبث
بتاريخ بالحياه الدستوريه الاسرائيليه ما
ابعاد ما يجري في هذا الصراع
في هذه المرحله الى اين يتجه هذا الصراع
ولكن لا شك انه يدل على انشقاق داخلي
قائمه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي ربما يجب
الاشاره قبل كل شيء هذا ليس صراع بين يمين
ويسار كما يحاول البعض ان يعرض ذلك هذا قد
يكون وصف سطحي نحن نتحدث عن خلاف بين
المركز اليمين المعتدل وبين اليمين
المتطرفه همم
الوطني
الخارطه اليمنيه هذا هو الخلاف من يعارض
القرارات التي اتخذها همم نتنياه لا ينتمي
الى اليسار وانما فعلا يخشى من ان هذه
التعديلات وهذه التغييرات قد تؤدي الى
تغيير النظام الاسرائيلي وهذا هو القلق
الاكبر هل فعلا سوف تتجه الامور الى ذلك
لا ولكن لا شك ان هذا القلق هو هذا ال-
ال- هذه المخاوف قائمه وحقيقيه شخصيات
قضائيه تحدثت وقالت ان اسرائيل تدخل همم
الى مصاف دكتاتوريه واقعه تحت السيطره
اغلبيه برلمانيه في حال جرت مثل هذه
التعديلات على الجسم القضائي في اسرائيل
هل هذا حديث هو حديث مبالغ به برايات
لا اطلاقا لا اولا همم لا نتحدث عن
بالضروره ان تكون
طريه همم بمعنى ان يكون هناك نظام مستبيد
عندما يتحدثون عن ذلك هناك بعض همم
الامثله في دول مختلفه في العالم في المجر
في اماكن همم اخرى حيث استغلت تم استغلال
النظام الديمقراطي والاغلبيه الديمقراطيه
لفرض الطابع او نظام من نوع اخر بمعنى
تقييد الحريات مانع بعض همم
القضايا الخاصه والتي تميز المجتمع اللي
براده وعندما يتم سلب هذه همم الحريات هذا
لا يجعل بالضروره النظام الديكتاتوريه
ولكن لا يجعله ايضا ديمقراطه ويجب ان
نتذكر بان النظام الديمقراطي في الصين هي
ديمقراطيه نسبيه بمعنى هناك جزء كبير لا
تزال مناطق الضفه الغربيه تحت الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ولا يزال اا ال- المواطنين
العرب في اسرائيل
يتميزون بالنوع من الديمقراطيه الجزئيه
لذلك الديموقراطيه ربما في اسرائيل هي
للاغلبيه اليهوديه
سوف نشهد بعض التغييرات التي قد تؤيد الى
تقليد هذه الديمقراطيه همم ديمقراطيه
لاغلبيه اسرائيليه يهوديه كما تتحدث الان
مع هذه التغييرات الى درجه
نتنياهو يفصل الجسم القضائي على مقاسه كما
يتهممه البعض بمثل هذه التعديلات
في الواقع حديث يدور عن انقلاب قضائي ليس
اقل من ذلك بمعنى ان تكون في نهايه الامر
السلطه الحاكمه هناك بين ال ما يميز
النظام الديمقراطي هو الفرق بين السلطات
المختلفه والسلطه القضائيه لها الاستقلال
عندما يتخذ نتنياهو هذه التعديلات وهذه
القرار هذا يعني بان في نهايه الامر
الحكومه هي التي تسيطر على الجهه القضائيه
وهي تستطيع ان تفرض قراراتها ورغباتها على
القضاه وعلى المحاكم وهذا ب- بالتحديد هذا
لا همم بعيدا عن النظام الديمقراطي كما
نعرفه
كيف تنظر الى حاله التوتر والتصعيد الامني
الاسرائيلي الكبير في الضفه الغربيه يوميا
تقريبا هناك شهيد
والمزيد من الجرح والمزيد من المعتقلين
وبين ما يجري في الدخل الاسرائيلي
اولا هذا التصعيد بدا قبل اشهر طويله في
شهر مارس الماضي بدا هذا التصعيد وهناك
مبررات واسباب اخرى لا علاقه بين التصعيد
خلال الاشهر الاخيره والتغيرات في الساحه
السياسيه الداخليه ولكن التغيرات في
الساحه السياسيه الداخليه ربما قد تجعل
هذا التصعيد وقد تجره الى نوع من فقدان
السيطره اذا ما اليوم تم تعيين رئيس جديد
نهايه الاركان والحديث وعلامات الاستفهام
التي تدور هل يستطيع الجيش ان يتبع نفس
الاساليب بمعنى على الاقل الحفاظ على
الهيكل القياده ام ان تكون هناك همم خارج
الجيش قد ايه تعطي الاوامر قد تحاول فرض
همم سيطرتها على مناطق الدفع الغربيه وهذا
نستطيع القول ربما هو الحلم الاكبر
للمتدينا همم في همم في الحكومه
همم قد يحاولون انتهاج هذه الفرصه
التاريخيه لهذا الغرض شكرا لك يا العليمه
همم من تل ابيب مراسله شؤون العسكريه في
راديو اسرائيل وارحب بضيفي من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الفلسطينيه ومن الخليل ايضا
السيد عادل شديد باحث المختص بشان
الاسرائيلي سيد عادل شديد همم مرحبا بك
ايضا معنا همم
البعض وصفه بانه همم يراها بانها اصلاحات
حسب نتنياهو حسب المؤيدين لا هو الاخر
وصفها بان ما يجري هو انقلاب حاله انقلاب
على الجهاز والجسم القضائي الاسرائيلي ما
الذي تراه انت وانت الخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين لا شك انه في
حال تم تنفيذ وترجمه ما اتفق عليه في
البرنامج الحكومي ما بين مكونات الحكومه
وتحديدا حزب النقود بزعامه نتنياهو من جهه
وباقي مكونات الحكومه سواء شاس او يهدوها
تراب
صهيونيه الدينيه والقوه اليهوديه الموضوع
ليس فقط انقلاب بقدر ما هو ثوره على كل م-
على كل المنظومه القضائيه والقانونيه في
اسرائيل ولكن واضح انه نتنياهو ليس منسجما
بشكل كامل مع مطالب بشركائه بالحكومه
وخاصه ما يتعلق في الجانب الليبرالي
الحقوق الفرديه موضوع
حقوق المثليين موضوع يفصل ما بين الجنسين
في المؤسسات في التعليم في المواصلات في
في كل الدوائر المختلفه نتنياهو يلتقي
معهم في موضوع همم محكمه العدل والحد من
تدخلات في الموضوع السياسي مثلا في موضوع
هدم المنازل الفلسطينيه في مناطق جيم
موضوعه همم سحب والغاء جنسيه مواطنين
فلسطينيين بالداخل حاصلين على الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه وما شابه
معني وت
ماما مدير في القوانين التي تجيز ملاحقه
رئيس حكومه وتحديدا ما يخصه ولكن بالقضايا
الاخرى اعتقد نتنياهو ليس معنيا ولكن غير
قادر على منح بسبب انه اولا هم الشبكه
والثانيه هو بحاجتهم وبدون همم شركتهم
بالحكومه لا يمكن لثانيه ان يشكل حكومه في
ظل معارضه واسعه في المجتمع اليهودي وكل
الاحوال اعتقد انه في حال ترجمه متفق عليه
نحن امام همم اكبر من انقلاب جديده وستكون
اسرائيل اسرائيل مختلفه ولكن من من جهه ما
يحدث
سيد مصطفى البرغوثي ما الذي تتوقع همم ان
تعكسه مثل هذه همم حاله التصدع هذه الصوره
التي تعيشها اسرائيل وتنقسم فيها الى
معسكري كيف يمكن ان تنعكس على الفلسطيني
في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
اولا انا رايي علينا ان نرى ما يجري يعني
في العمق وليس فقط ما يجري على سطح
الاحداث في العمق اعتقد ان الحركه
الصهيونيه التي هي خلف كل الحكومات
الاسرائيليه دخلت في ازمه عميقه وانعكاس
هذه الازمه يعني او نجمت هذه الازمه في
الواقع عن فشلها في امرين فشلها في اخراج
الشعب الفلسطيني من ارض وطنه واليوم عدد
الفلسطينيين اكثر من عدد اليهود
الاسرائيليين وثانيا فشلها في وقف
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي هذه الازمه
دفعت بهذه الحركه الى الفاشيه وعلى فكره
الفاسيه اخطر بكثير من الديكتاتوريه الذي
يجري الان هو تفتت الداخلي ايضا اسرائيلي
في موضوع القضاء في موضوع المحكمه العليا
في موضوع الفساد
رئيس الوزراء ووزير الداخليه متهمان
بالفساد وهذه الحكومه تهدد بقمع حريه
الراي والتعبير الى درجه انها تريد
كنيسه منتخبين وهدد بعضهم باعتقال جانسو
لبيد اذا حاله التفتت الداخلي تعكس تطور
فاشي خطير ينعكس على ليس فقط الفلسطينيين
بل على اسرائيل نفسها من ناحيه
الفلسطينيين انا برايي هذا الذي يجري ادى
الى يعني يعكس حاله تحول نوعي كبير
فلسطينيا اولا هناك تحول شعبي بادراك عميق
انه لا حل وسط مع الحركه الصهيوني التي
اصبحت فشيه
الاعتراك عميق انه لا حلسه تغيير ميزان
القوه عبر المقاومه والكفاح وان اسرائيل
لا تفهم الا لغه القوه الامر الثاني هناك
وحده ميدانيه تتكون وتتجاوز التنظيمات
افضل يعني المقاومون تجاوز وتنظيماتهم في
هذه الوحده النضاليه التي يصنعوها على
الارض وثا هناك ادراك عميق بان وحده وطنيه
فلسطينيه يجب ان تتكون الان على اساس
برنامج كفاح مقاومه من ناحيه التطور
الفاشل في اسرائيل هذا يفتح الان فر عظيمه
للنضال الوطني الفلسطيني للمطالبه بعزل
ومقاطعه اسرائيل
والمطالبه بعزلها دوليا والتطور الفاشى
يساعدنا على ذلك لانه هو في الواقع يعكس
فكر عنصري شديد جدا مما قاله السيد مصطفى
البرغوثي وخاصه بان هذه الحكومه ايضا تقوم
بتعينات لشخصيات متشدده مثلا بمناصب حساسه
مثلا
تعيين رئيس اركان مثل هاليفي بهذه الصوره
وخلفياته هذه وبخطابه الموجهه بصوره يعني
مباشره وخطيره بالتجاه الفلسطيني في حاله
من امنت الصراع وتوجيه باتجاه الفلسطيني
كالعاده
يعني موضوع
استلام هرسي عليه في اليوم
رئاسه الاركاني يا مساله متفق عليها قبل
الانتخابات الحاليه يعني موضوع عادي ضمن
تغييرات في رؤساء الالكان
ومرضي من
المعايير والمحطات العسكريه اللي تاهل هذا
الموقع وان كان له مواقف ولكن بالموضوع
الفلسطينيات بالشارع الاسرائيلي كما اعلن
انه سيكون اسبوعيا وكل مساء السبت همم
مظاهره واسعه في تل ابيب وفي القدس امام
منزلوا وفي حال تطور هذا الخطاب الاحتجاجي
الى ممارسات عمليه
عصيان مدني كما الدوعيه وكما و و ورفض
المحاميين الامتثال امام المحاكم وسوى رفض
قطاع ايضا العمل وفق القوانين الجديد ورفض
افراد من الشرطه
الامتثال لتعليمات الشرطه كما تم الدعوه
من قبل رؤساء اركان ووزراء جيش واضح انه
من الممكن في لحظه معك ان يخرج نتنياهو ان
ياخذ المنطقه بالمكتب اتجاه مواجهه مع
الفلسطينيين قد تكون غزه قد تكون في في
مكان اخر ولكن علينا ان ان ان ان نقل
الوطن
داخل الدوله الان باتجاه الفلسطيني هو
خيار دائما موجود ومناسب ليله مياهه او
للحكومات الاسرائيليه كخيار مثل هذا
الخيار همم دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي برايك
همم كيف سيجري التعامل معه فلسطينيه خاصه
ما تبعناه اليوم ايضا من اخراج هذا
الفيديو لكتائب القسام للاسير الاسرائيلي
الجندي الاسرائيليها
طبعا هناك نقطه مهمه هنا ان الخلاف
الداخلي الاسرائيلي يعني باستثناء اقليه
صغيره
المختلفون هم كلهم متفقون ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني يعني لبيد وجانس كانوا مسؤولين
عن جرائم كبيره ارتكبت ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
لذلك علينا ان نفهم ان خلافاتهم الداخليه
لا تؤثر في موقفهم من الاساءه من العدوان
على الشعب الفلسطيني لكن من ناحيه اخرى
انا برايي الذي يجري ايضا يؤكد انه ما في
سبيل امام الفلسطينيين الان الا ان
يستعدوا لانه فعلا محتمل جدا ان تصاعد هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهي تهدد اصلا
بممارسه التطهير عرقي ومن هنا المطلوب على
المستوى الشعبي طبعا تصعيد المقاومه
وتوحيدها ولكن ايضا مطلوب على المستوى
الرسمي اجراءات تتردد جهات الرسميه في
اتخاذها وهذا غير مبرر بما في ذلك وقف
التنسيق التنسيق الامني مع هذه الحكومه
الفاشيه وبما في ذلك التحلل من اتفاق وبما
في ذلك تبني نهج المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات
على اسرائيل وحكومتها بشكل كامل وهذه امور
جذريه يجب اتخاذها ايضا انا برايي الذين
ينظروا للفاشيه والتفوق العرق اليهود الان
يجب ان يعطونا فرصه لمكافحه التطبيع
والمطالبه بوقف هذا التطبيع الذي جرى من
حكومات عربيه والاستجابه لراي شعوب هذه
الدول بوقف التطبيع مع اسرائيل سيد عادل
شديد هل سيهرب نتنياهو الى الامام بتقديم
مثلا ورقه امنيه فلسطينيه للشارع الكيه
يهدا ام انه سيضع مثلا هذه الملفات التي
يريد تعديلها حسب وجهه نظره امام الجمهور
الاسرائيلي بانه امر واقع وهذا هو الموجود
استاذ السياسه ولديه الكثير من الاوراق
والبدائل
سيحاول الاستفاده من تحركات الشارع باتجاه
تخفيف مطالب شركاؤه بالحكومه والذهاب فقط
في الامور المتفق عليها التي تحدثنا على
ما يخص محكمه العدل العليا والتدخل
بالقضايا الفلسطينيه هدم المنازل وسحب
الجنسيات وما شابه وموضوع الملاحقه
الفاسدين
ولكن مساله الذهاب باتجاه الفلسطينيين
المساله ورد جدا وبالمناسبه وقد يكون
تصعيد على ساحه النقب الفلسطينيه يعني
هنالك اتفاق ما بين معظم مركبات الحكومه
الحالي بعدم ابقاء الوضع الفلسطيني بالنقب
كما هو سمعنا تعبيرات فاشيه جدا وصلت الى
الى حد منع الانجاب واعطاء وعبر
للنساء الفلسطينيات في النقب للحج همم من
الانجاب بمعنى انه الخيارات امام نتانيا
ولكن يبقى الخيار باتجاه التصعيد امام
الفلسطينيين وارد لسبب بسيط ان ان هنالك
اجماع صهيوني ليس فقط داخل حكومه وانما
لكل المكونات المجتمعيه ثم اا ثم انه انه
انه للضعاف الحراك المجتمعي والمظاهرات لا
يمكن ان ان ان ان ان يوقفوا بدون مواجهه
الدمويه مع فلسطين حينها يظهر المحتجين
وكانهم خونه وعملاء امام شارع الاسراء ان
الازمه الحاليه في اسرائيل ليست ازمه
دستوريا لسبب بسيط انه لا يجد السوري لو
كان هنالك دستور في اسرائيل لدى اسرائيل
كان من الممكن
العزمي ما بين الحركه الصهيونيه ما بين
الحركه الصهيونيه بشقها العلماني همم اللي
بمثلو- بالنسبه يوم السبت على المظاهرات
الحكومه الحاليه اهو والصهيونيه الدينيه
والصهيونيه المتطرفه اللي بتشكي دكتور
مصطفى اني يتعامل ازاءه هذا النشاط خاصه
بان حتى لو اختلف همم
اسرائيل هي السياسه الاسرائيلي في الداخل
الاسرائيلي لكنهم جميعهم طالما كانوا
متفقين على الفلسطيني
السبيل الوحيد هو ان نتوحد الان في قياده
وطنيه موحده على برنامج وطني كفاحي مقاوم
وان نضع خططا عمليه وملموسه لما سنواجه
وانا في الواقع اريد ان احيي صمود ابناء
شعبنا وبنات شعبنا في كل مكان ولكن انا
احذر ان هناك اربع نقاط معرضه للخطر الان
ويجب وضع كل الطاقات لدعم صمودها الخائن
الاحمر الشيخ جراح مساء في الرياض يطا
المسجد الاقصى نفسه كل هذه المواقع معرض
الان لخطر هذه الهجمه الصهيونيه الخطيره
ولهذه الحكومه الفاشيه لذلك الان ليس
امامنا الا ان نتوحد يجب تنحيه الخلافات
جانبا وتوحيد كل الطاقات الفلسطينيه على
برنامج كفاحي مقاومه شكرا
ايضا ضيفي من الخليل السيد عادل شديد بحث
مختصر بشان الاسرائيلي شكرا لكم
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
ورق الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]